ganz egal wie lange ich in der Küche
steht ganz egal wie aufwendig die
Gerichte sind die ich koche oder an
welchen entlegenen Winkel der Welt ich
fahre damit ich etwas besonderes Essen
kann ihr und auch ich gebe zu lieben
bestellvideos deshalb ist es heute
wieder soweit ich bestelle bei drei
verschiedenen Restaurants die noch nicht
bewertet wurden das ist einfach jedes
Mal wie eine kleine Wundertüte
dementsprechend habe ich auch heute
wieder große Lust darauf weil es kann
sein dass wir die erste Rezension
schreiben und das Restaurant ist übelst
geil oder ist es verdammt ich hoffe
natürlich dass es nicht verdammt sondern
dass wir nur leckeres Essen bekommen
aber in der Vergangenheit war das auch
nicht immer der Fall deshalb suchen wir
uns drei Restaurants raus bestellen wir
und lassen wir es uns hoffentlich
schmecken so dann wollen wir mal in die
App gehen gucken uns das Ganze an ihr
seht es schon 636 Restaurants wir
Filtern einmal nach Bewertung zack dann
wir oben die wunderbaren schönen fünf
Sterne Restaurants bei den wir heute
nicht bestellen dürfen sondern wir gehen
all the way runter unter die aller
schlechtesten wenn da verstecken sich
die noch nicht bewerteten Restaurants da
geht's los Pizza zeigen
und Jerry Brauhaus Sushi Bubble Tea Papa
Josef Kölner Döner Burger also wirklich
jede Menge noch nicht bewertete
Restaurants das erste Restaurant bei dem
wir bestellen werden ist Brauhaus tünnes
und Schäl 0 Sterne aus Null Bewertung
klar die sehen hier schon Sauerbraten
rheinische Art gegrillte Schweinshaxe
wurstteller Fitness Teller das ist auf
jeden Fall so ein klassisches Brauhaus
ich weiß nicht ob es bei jedem von euch
sowas auch in der Nähe gibt aber in Köln
sind Brauhaus natürlich eine Sache und
in Köln nimmt man braucht auch nicht auf
die leichte Schulter deshalb muss das
auf jeden Fall was taugen würde ich mal
sagen schnitzelkölle fahren ja
Kochschinken Ananas Käse oh jo jo
deftiges Rindergulasch wann habe ich das
letzte Mal Gulasch gegessen das wäre
krass aber Sauerbraten wir auch krass
ich glaube ich mache es einfach wenn da
steht beliebtes Gericht bestätigen
Sauerbraten Sauerbraten kann auch
entweder geil oder deshalb ist es
eigentlich ein gutes Test Gericht 19,90
€ gefühlt schon teuer also ich finde
wenn ich sie mir so vorstelle ich
bestelle mir das zu essen dann für eine
Portion 19 ist das schon teuer aber ich
bestelle und dann schauen wir nach dem
nächsten Laden erste bestellung ist raus
schauen wir nach der zweiten nicht
möchtest diesmal ein bisschen zufällig
halten
Omi Bar gehen wir mal drauf dort gibt es
Sushi augenscheinlich kalte Vorspeisen
warme Vorspeisen Suppen sushi-mix
hosemarke nigeriashimi Maki special
rosemporary also anscheinend die ganze
Bandbreite ich bin direkt mal zu
hauptgerichteten gesprungen ich glaube
flying Omi Bar gebratene breitbandnudeln
mit Gegrilltem Lachsfilet wenn das schon
den Namen vom Restaurant im
gerichtsnamen hat dann muss es
eigentlich gut sein und gebratene Nudeln
immer geil gegrilltes Lachsfilet klingt
auch sehr gut ich glaube das ist meine
zweite Bestellung und der letzte Laden
heißt
Pizzeria DAOs beliebt Penne Hähnchen
hollandas aber wenn das erste Gericht
Hände Hähnchen Hollandaise ist ich wenn
man nicht vorgenommen sein schauen wir
mal was es sonst noch so gibt das finde
ich aber interessant Penne Hähnchen mit
Putenstreifen Hähnchen oder Pute was
jetzt und so ist sondern das in
tomatensame Soße Soße sondern das mit
Sahnesoße das ist eigentlich so pervers
dass man schon fast bestellen muss aber
kann das überhaupt gut sein
nudelbox Hollandaise Penne mit Sauce
Hollandaise einfach nur Penne mit Sauce
Hollandaise ich bestelle jetzt diese
erste Pasta egal vielleicht ist sie
nicht gut oder aber ich erlebe eine
riesen Überraschung Penne Hähnchen
Hollandaise ab geht's letzte Bestellung
ich habe Angst die erste Bestellung ist
da und ich habe wirklich unglaublich
viel Hunger deshalb schauen wir einmal
gemeinsam rein es ist unser Sauerbraten
und mama mia er war wirklich nicht ganz
günstig wie ich meinte aber das ist ein
richtiger Apparat also ich will nicht
lügen aber das sind bestimmt 8 900 g
also es ist wirklich viel und
wahrscheinlich oh guckt euch das mal an
also ist es irgendwie falsch finde ich
so einen Sauerbraten in so einer
Styroporverpackung zu sehen aber guckt
euch das mal an wir haben wirklich die
beiden Klöße alles ist noch so leicht am
dampfen Rotkohl sieht super aus
Sauerbraten sieht auch gut aus und ich
habe da gerade richtig Lust drauf das
erste Mal dass ich dieses Jahr Knödel
esse oder Klöße esse probieren wir zu
allererst einmal den Rotkohl weil meine
Mama macht den besten der Welt und das
wirklich keinen Spaß also ich glaube so
eine unabhängige Jury würde sagen dass
dann haben wir den krassen rot gemacht
deshalb bin ich da immer sehr befangen
bei Rotkohl von anderen Köchen
wo er schon echt gut nicht so gut wie
bei einer mom aber sehr sehr gut man
sieht auch glaube ich ein Pfefferkorn
also dass der so so richtig so selbst
gekocht wird also das ist nicht
irgendwie aus dem Glas das würde man
also schmeckt man auch dass er nicht aus
dem Glas ist sondern die stellen sich
schon hin Kochen in Rotkohl selbst das
ist schon mal ein Pluspunkt aber davon
noch irgendwo erwarten weil die 20 €
boah ich bin schon mal froh davon werde
ich auf jeden Fall satt und glücklich
egal wie gut oder schlecht die anderen
Sachen sein werden ich gehe mal an den
Klostern perfekt geformte Klöße noch
Kartoffelklöße das sieht man schon mit
Bratensoße vor Bratensoße nee durch das
beste der Welt gute Soßen sind immer
wieder der Inbegriff von einer guten
Kirche es macht mich glücklicher als ich
gerade machen sollte also bisher voller
Erfolg daran ich probieren
ich habe zu lange keine Klöße gegessen
wirklich geil auch mit der Bratensoße
sehr unpoint jetzt kommen wir aber zu
den Part der aber bei einem gelieferten
Essen wahrscheinlich am schwierigsten
richtig zu machen ist nämlich dem
Sauerbraten und ich meine Sauerbraten
ist nicht das weiße der Welt aber wenn
ich immer so rein steche mit der
Messerspitze es geht auf jeden Fall
glaube ich schon weicher
das sind aber auch noch Rosinen dabei
auch hier auf jeden Fall wieder so eine
traditionelle Zubereitung und ich bin
mir sicher dass es alles selbst gekocht
so ne also das die Latte hängt tief
gerade das auch sowas wie Rotkohl
selbstgemacht ist finde ich schon gut
also alleine für diese Bratensoße bin
ich schon Fan von dem Restaurant muss
ich wirklich sagen
boah richtig geil also wirklich
insgesamt Hammer gut wenn ich das ganze
bewerten müsste selbst bewerten müsste
was ich auch später im Anschluss tun
werde teuer schon irgendwie es ist nicht
ganz günstig wenn ich das allerdings für
20 Euro im Restaurant an meinem Platz
serviert bekommen würde würde ich sagen
okay 20 € sind fein so weil es halt
wirklich Hochwasser tief ist weil die
selbst kochen weil die gute Zutaten
haben warum sollte es dann also
günstiger sein wenn man sogar noch nach
Hause geliefert bekommt deshalb ist das
für mich ein absoluter win ich würde dem
Restaurant damit starten wir auf jeden
Fall sportlich rein ich glaube ich würde
würde es unfair wenn die keine fünf
Sterne richtig gut ab zur nächsten also
Leute das war ja schon mal nicht ganz
verkehrt aber sag mal so viel es kann ja
durchaus passieren das wird noch etwas
bekommen was nicht wirklich gut ist
anders als bei meinem Partner hallo
fresh denn da kriegt ihr immer nur die
Sachen geliefert auf die ihr Lust habt
jede Woche neu zusammengestellt und ihr
könnt Euch sicher gehen dass es Euch
auch schmecken wird denn da kriegt ihr
eine kochbox nach Hause geliefert von
professionellen Köchen zusammengestellt
nach eurem Geschmack und jedes mal
frisch jedes Mal aufs Neue ein voller
Erfolg HelloFresh der jede Woche zu
einem entspann sogenannten Alltag du
musst nicht mehr stundenlang durch den
Verkehr Einkaufen alles nach Hause
schleppen wir Gericht überlegen nein das
übernimmt alles HelloFresh für dich ich
meine ich weiß wie schwierig das ist
wenn man irgendwie noch zur Schule geht
studiert oder natürlich auch einen
Vollzeitjob arbeitet man kann das schon
mal schwer fallen all diese Sachen
selbst zu machen und deshalb finde ich
so ein Angebot wie HelloFresh wirklich
gut HelloFresh nimmt die nicht nur den
Einkauf ab sondern mach auf das
überlegen gleich da denn du kriegst eine
Vorauswahl von Gerichten wo immer etwas
für jeden dabei ist seines Vaters braves
Käse Spätzle Sandwiches das alles gibt
es auch in vegetarisch vegan oder
familienfreundlich dementsprechend ist
auf jeden Fall für jeden etwas dabei das
Beste ist das HelloFresh superflexibel
ist wenn du Besuch bekommst bestellst du
einfach ein paar Portion mehr wenn du im
Urlaub bist pausierst du dein Abo oder
lässt es dir in den Urlaub liefern also
es ist wirklich denkbar einfach und vor
allem eins nämlich komfortabel auch
nicht zu vernachlässigen die Lieferanten
von HelloFresh sind lokal und hochwertig
die Verpackungen sind recycelt und die
Lieferung erfolgt klimaneutreiben und
das beste ich habe natürlich einen Code
für euch nämlich den Code fresh Max mit
dem könnt ihr in Deutschland und
Österreich bis zu 90 Euro und in der
Schweiz sogar bis zu 140 Franken auf die
ersten vier Boxen sparen klingt ein
bisschen kompliziert kleines
Rechenbeispiel bei drei Gerichten für
vier Personen zahlt man pro Person nur
zwei Euro 33 pro Gericht also zum
ausprobieren vielleicht auch nur wenn
euch gerade langweilig ist ist das auf
jeden Fall ziemlich fair also klicke
jetzt auf den Link in der Beschreibung
auf meinen Link löst meinen Code ein
fresh Max Dankeschön an HelloFresh dass
sie dieses Video unterstützen und viele
viele Projekte auf meinem Kanal
überhaupt erst ermöglichen weiter geht's
mit der nächsten Bestellung die nächste
Bestellung ist da und es ist die dritte
die wir getätigt haben ich weiß die
zweite Sache aber wir wollen das alles
fair bleiben und wollen die Sachen
natürlich auch warm essen so wie sie
ankommt sieht fast aus wie so ein
Kunstprojekt so ein bisschen diese
besondere Pasta welchen ein bisschen
kritisch gegenüber stehen so
Interessantes lieferkonzept so zwei
ineinander gesteckte to go Boxen und das
hier ist also
und so sieht das ganze in unserer
nudelbox aus also das hier ist
wahrscheinlich Hähnchen oder Pute einen
eindeutigen Verbund aus Sauce
Hollandaise und Sahne soßig ist das ganz
auf jeden Fall guck mal Geschmäcker sind
verschieden was kann ich bewerten sind
die Nudeln alte das ist ja schon mal so
eine Anfang ich sage euch ehrlich ich
werde probiere mich darauf einzulassen
das ist bescheuert das ist wirklich
einfach Sauce Hollandaise als Soße ich
wie viel Kalorien haben diese Nudeln so
muss man das doch zur Hälfte Butter oder
so was soll ich sagen irgendwie
irgendeine Ecke von meinem Kopf sagt
geil weil es halt so pures Fett ist aber
man könnte auch einfach so Nudeln mit
Mayo Essen das hätte so den gleichen
Effekt
die Nudeln sind auf jeden Fall gut
gekocht so vom Garpunkt die sind nicht
so matschig oder sind auch nicht zu hart
es ist einfach so ein bisschen komisches
Gericht ich glaube ihr merkt gerade ich
bin erschüttert weil ich weiß nicht was
ich denken soll weil irgendwie schmeckt
es sich eklig aber es ist halt so eine
absurde Kreation Tenne mit Sauce
Hollandaise und Hähnchen oder putis
schmecken kann
würde sagen das ist Hähnchen schmeckt
auch nicht schlecht es ist jetzt nicht
geil aber es ist halt auch das was ich
bestellt habe Nudeln mit Sauce
Hollandaise und Hähnchen aber so von der
Umsetzung her bekommt man eigentlich das
was man erwartet deshalb gebe ich dem
ganzen glaube ich drei von fünf Sterne
werde ich nicht normal bestellen aber
ich kann mir wirklich vorstellen dass es
Leute gibt die das gerne mögen also
vielleicht auch ein bisschen dumm von
mir dass ich bestellt habe machen wir
weiter mit der nächsten Bestellung
unsere dritte Bestellung von umi-bar und
ich muss schon mal sagen vom
lieferkonzept her ist das super also die
haben sich auf jeden Fall Gedanken
gemacht schöne Abtrennung das hält das
Essen perfekt warm hier drüben haben wir
den Kostentreiber vom Gericht nämlich
den gegrillten Lachs mit ein bisschen so
geschnibbeltem Gemüse und da drüben
haben wir die Nudeln welche es ist auch
wirklich gerade eben angekommen äh schon
ziemlich angetrocknet sind das ist
natürlich ein dickes Manko also ich kann
da wahrscheinlich einfach einmal
reinstechen und den Block Nudeln
rausholen schade da kann auch immer der
Lieferservice mit dran schuld sein aber
bei den anderen beiden hatten jetzt
keine größeren Probleme es ist auf jeden
Fall jetzt auf den ersten Blick schon so
ein sieht gesund aus so als würde so ein
bisschen Lachs ein bisschen Gemüse
Nudeln ausgewogenes Mittagessen was man
sich da bestellen kann aber es sollte
wahrscheinlich nicht nur ausgewogen sein
sondern auch richtig gut schmecken wenn
es 18 € kostet also man sieht richtig
der ist sogar schön glasig das sieht
schon nicht verkehrt aus richtig saftig
das weiß vielleicht so vom
Spannungsbogen her nicht das beste aber
ich möchte auf jeden Fall die Lachs
probieren
boah der ist wirklich sehr sehr saftig
krass das so geliefert hätte ich nicht
gedacht also krass guckt euch das noch
mal an also man sieht wirklich richtig
krass der ist super saftig gebraten ich
verstehe warum das so das signature
gerichtet warum die Flying nudels Omi
Wahrheiten das schon geil dass man das
so gut geliefert bekommt ist special
geil dazu die Nudeln
die schmecken nicht schlecht ne aber die
sind an einem Block wo die kriegst auch
nicht auseinander da wäre sowas wie Reis
vielleicht sogar geiler einfach als
Beilage weil es halt besser funktioniert
die sind auch ein bisschen fettig die
Nudeln also wenn ich in welchem Block
einmal raus hebe da unten steht halt
auch so richtig das Öl drin die Nudeln
sind nicht mein Favorit der Lachs
überrascht mich sehr sehr positiv und
das Gemüse probiere ich auch mal boah
das hat auch richtig bis schmeckt
richtig frisch geil auf jeden Fall nicht
verkehrt heißt treiben ist der Lachs da
ist ja auch richtig viel Lachs dabei
kann man auch wirklich nichts dagegen
sein so zwei fette Scheiben Lachs schön
durchgebraten trotzdem glasig der ist
super daher klar Preis auch hier hoch
aber irgendwo auch gerechtfertigt ihr
könnt ja mal in die Kommentare schreiben
was für euch der Favorit ist heutigen
Tages war ich würde irgendwie sagen weil
es mit den Nudeln echt doof ist vier
fünf hat mir drei vier fünf mein Favorit
ist dem nach klar das Brauhaus wirklich
vielleicht ist meine Begeisterung nicht
ganz rübergekommen aber das war wirklich
wirklich richtig gut nichtsdestotrotz
hat wieder große Freude bereitet ein
paar noch nicht bewertete Restaurants zu
testen zu bewerten und das Video mit
euch zu teilen Check wie gesagt
HelloFresh ab und danke fürs hier drüben
gibt es noch ein für dich
vorgeschlagenes Video individuell nur
für dich und darunter kannst du meinen
Kanal abonnieren danke schön bis zum
nächsten Mal ciao
[Musik]